thank you all for coming just a few
short remarks one is this is a
boot camp i asked the
lecturers to prepare their lectures so
that the experts would be bored
it's an opportunity to learn something
new
and you math is not a spectator sport so
i also
for people giving lecture series they
have made up some homework problems for
you
those are printed out or they're on your
inbox
either way and we're even going to have
sessions where we go over those problems
and those are straightforward problems
so you should work on them
and learn something outside your
expertise this is the week
where you should learn something outside
your expertise so without further ado
i would like to introduce our first
speaker lojo menedel
cnrs and university of montenegro he's
going to speak on gmail for complexity
theory first of two lectures
okay of course i want to thank the
organizers for
involving me in this exciting program
so i've been asked to be very elementary
so i'll try to
so my goal is to try to give you an idea
of what geometry can
be allowed to do in terms of complexity
i will essentially not say anything
about complexity theory in itself but
it's not from
the species and so i will focus more on
a
foreign mathematical question which is
uh can we compare
the determinant the permanent
so that's rather the focus of
the talk will be determined here is
permanent
and really more precisely what what can
we learn from geometry
so this looks like really a purely
algebraic problem
so why would it be interesting to use
geometry and what
geometry can tell us about this problem
why and how geometry
so today i want to give you some some
background on this question
and give you a first result which really
improved by geometric tools and then
next time i will
try to reformulate the
problem you know
under break a liberal geometric language
and try to understand what could be a
strategy to
try to answer to this question
okay so let's begin from the start so
the determinant
so you take a matrix and
so again the space of the matrices of
cinnamon
throw the other pen away
so end times and mattresses
i just had them put your pencils
so n times n matrices of course you know
that the determinant can be
just expressed as a sum of permutations
this is the set of permutations
of n symbols permutations have signs
which are denoted by epsilon sigma
okay
and you have this very familiar
expression
so then the permanent
is essentially the same
polynomial on the mattresses
except that we forget the signs
even simpler
let's take the product let's take the
usual expansion that you don't care
about
so it turns out there's this polynomials
which are
at first sight
very similar should be in fact deeply
different in nature so at least so
obviously you can say that this
polynomial is the same
if you work with a field of
characteristic too
so we will avoid avoid this case so
we're essentially thinking
characteristic zero
it's like work let's let's work overseas
so why why are these polynomials very
different well first the determinant is
really
as you know very nice it's easy to
compute
many reasons many reasons of course you
know
line and column expansions you have all
kinds of transformations that you have
to compute
determinants easily there have been
books and books written about that
but the maybe the essential point is
that the determinant is really
multiplicative so the determinant of a
product of matrices
is a product of the determinant so
that's really what allows you to compute
it
efficiently you can take a matrix
x and multiply by matrices which will
give you some involved operations
possibly but in the end
you control very well with determinants
okay so that's a character
and the linear group so that's really
what i explained
my point of view the fact that the
determinant is easy to cut
in terms of algebraic algebraic
complexity classes it is
normal time the permanent
still has some nice properties so you
can still
expand two lines and columns
so first nail operation you can do for
determinants you can
also allow it for fragments then of
course you don't have this
multiplicative property
there are some formulas which allow you
to to compute the
the permanent more efficiently but then
just by
taking the defining formula so for
example we have um
so it will be important to keep track of
the size of the metric so we
denote that so n determinant of
n by n matrices
okay so so one nice formula
is the following so you take the sum
over
or subsets of indices
there is a sign which is
minus one to the power the size of the
complement of
the set
and then you take the product over
the line index and the product
of the sums so you take
for each line only the columns
corresponding to the set that you have
chosen
so this gives you a nice way to compute
the problem
so you have some efficient formulas
which
okay so you should have something like
um n square 2 to the n
operations to do to compute the
so valiant proved that permanent is hard
to compute in a sense
just precise which is sharply hard
and so one of the questions is
can we just distinguish this this class
on this one for example
by proving that the permanent is
fundamentally different from the
determinant
so how can you prove that the prominent
is really hard to compute
so one approach is to try to express the
prominent
in terms of a determinant okay so if the
permanent is
can be computed efficiently one way
would be to express it as a determinant
okay so we can rewrite the permanent
as a determinant of another
of course but some something
which we defined in terms of x and which
would
be given given by some defined number
we asked the entries of this matrix to
be a fine expression of the entries of x
okay so priorities
so they should not be possible since
permanent is pretty difficult
to compute the determinant is so there
is a cost in doing this
which is that we will need to expand the
size of the matrix
if we compute the permanent of a matrix
of size n
maybe you can do that but priority for
some matrix
which would be a bigger size
m will be bigger
than m and the question is what is
exactly the cost of this operation
so of course if you um try the small
values of that then
things seems to be
easy at the beginning so just
to change one side and you get the
permanent from the table
but then things go wrong quite quite
fast
so let me give you an answer for 3x4
mattresses
if you take a three by three mattress
matrix and you want to compute its
furniture
so you can write it at the determinant
of the following matrix
so it's not a complicated matrix
zeroes
so you can do it but uh first remark is
that
it's not so obvious and uh
we had to censor give us
seven by seven metrics
i don't know how to find this better
so it seems we have to increase the size
of the matrix in a
very strong
that way be done in six places
i don't know is it
no it's five six or seven
so we'll see in the end of the lecture
that you can
take a three or four by four matrix but
five six or seven
so what we really care about is what
happens synthetically so
if we take enlarge which l are we able
to
to use okay so there is definition
which is the determinant of complexity
so we call the determinant complexity
so it can be fine for any polynomial but
let's look at some
improvements
so it's the smallest
multigerm
so
such that we can want
the permanent
it has a determinant of the
matrix with a refined entries
a size m
okay so we've seen that elemental
complexity of prime two is two
and a complexity of country.7
so what else
so it's interesting to have a
bounce level grounds
it's a question so far
so i want to give you a proof of
following statement
that the determinant complexity of
from n is at most two to the n minus one
okay gives you a way to express the
prominence as a determinant
but this hopefully
okay so we so the proof comes from a
graph theory
that's also one of the uh interests of
the permanent substance
that i mean so reason why it isn't
so relevant in complexity theory is that
it is relevant in graph theory
it allows to compute certain data
associated to graphs
it's also the case of determinants let's
see how it works
so give you a few general definitions so
let gamma be an oriented graph
final graph an oriented finding
okay so we have a finite set of vertices
final set of edges
and then there is the classical notion
of adjacency matrix
okay this is vertices of the
graph
and it tells you there is a ledger from
outer j you put a one
there is an oriented edge from i to j
and zero
so this gives you all the information so
it really defines your craft
and then so the question is so what is
the determinant of this matrix
express what is the combinatorial
content of the determinant of this
matrix
okay so just look at the
formula
there were some of our permutations in
these
quantities right one sigma one
and single ends so let's n is the
size of the graph so the number of
vertices
so how can such a monogamous be non-zero
so we need of course each of these
entries to be to be one that means there
is an arrow there is an edge from one to
signal one
okay so for each of our
edges we have a for each of our vertices
we have
one edge
the source is this vertex
and we have another edge whose target in
this vertex
yes
so in the end a non-zero maneuver
okay so we have a series of edges like
this so
eventually we will come back
so you see that the non-zero monomial
corresponds to what is called
cyclic covering
okay basically covering you let's see
what it means the partition of the graph
in this joint union of cycles
any possibility to split your graph into
a digital union of cycles
like that which contributes to a
non-zero
polynomial in your determinant
okay so then you have a sign so here the
permanent would be better it would just
compute the number
of uh cyclic coverings here you have a
assigned a number of signed cyclic
coverings
that's the result the determinant of a
is the number
oops it's not really a number it's
better to be
okay number of sign
cyclic coverings organa
okay
so now we just compute numbers so we're
better
interested in complete polynomials so
you can modify slightly the
construction instead of looking to just
an oriented graph
you can consider some weighted crap
which means that for each edge
we choose a weight
xrj
coherent with these usual locations
so you can
now replace the adjacency matrix by the
matrix
of weights okay considering the weight
to be zero if there is no knowledge at
all
and then the result is the uh
we have just the same
same expression except that we have um
weight here
so in the end what contributes to this
determinant is again
this family of cyclic coverings but the
contribution is the product of the
weights
do you need them to consider it can you
just not consider undirected
because you know the edge is directly a
certain way you just need it
okay i could also do that for
non-narrative graphs
it's the same as putting graphs with
arrows on both sides
of course there are many variants
so in the end the result is not just
sign number of signs if you're covering
but
remember so maybe the sum
of the weights
i would say click cover
and so the idea is now that if we take
these weights to be some determinants
of some expression another expression
and something like that and then we'll
include some polynomial
so that's what we want to do for the
permanent
so
consider the following graph
so the vertices
will be the subset the subsets of
and then element set
choose an integer vertices
where is there something to do which is
this
you have to identify the vertex
corresponding to the empty set
with the vertex corresponding to the
full set
what will be the edges
we will have an edge from s to t
with the weight which will be fixed ij
white so i
will be the number of elements in t
and t is required to be the union of s
with this
goal three what would you get so we
start with the
empty set one two three
so this gives us x one because
this has one element and one because we
have that added the integer one
two
then we go to one two one three two
three
so here for example the weight the
weight would be
x2 because this has two elements and two
because we added two from here
okay so let's set one to three
which remember is the same vertex here
is in fact the same
so this is the graph plus
we need to add some other edges
which are just loops
from s to s or s
different from the special vertex and
here the weight is just one of these
loops
this is the girl
see a 7x7 matrix is a special case like
this
precisely
adjacency matrix size 2 to the n minus
1.
so now we want to compute the
determinant
okay so we have to uh find the cyclic
coverings
of the graph so how can we have a
cyclic covering so
so what one of the cycle we will include
the special vertex
and then the only way to have a cycle
in this vertex is to follow the edges by
adding one integer
recovery will be get one by choosing a
pad like that
from top to bottom this is a cycle
because these two vertices
once you have chosen this cycle well
what can you do nothing
there's no other possibility if you
start from here
to come back because you will be obliged
to
pass through the special vertex the only
possibility
that remains once you have chosen this
path is to choose the remaining loops
okay so this is a cyclic covering and
all the secret coverings are labeled
are given by choose a pass from top to
bottom
and then the loops
sorry the middle line from top to bottom
is not the side correct
it is a cycle because the remember that
we have identified
the top and the bottom
okay so now what is the determinant is
the sum of
so each time we we add an integer so
this
this is encoded in the permutation
sequence of this interest
so the weight is exactly
the monomial we expect the loops
contribute by once
and then there is a there was a sign
not to forget okay so the sign
remember this the cycles are
contributed by the sign and the sign the
sine contribution of a cycle is minus
one to the
length of the cycle minus one
okay so the loop contributes to
to nothing and then here we have a
cycle of length n minus one it
contributes to
minus one to nine two so the
contribution is not
always plus one but the point is that it
does not depend on the path
so up to a sign we really have
the permanent the other body matrix and
of course the designer can
put it in the detergent but changing on
a line approach
for this trick tail
so yes adventure white if you if you
express the adjacency matrix for this
very graph you
get this expression
okay so you know how to express the
permanent as the determinant of the
public matrix this side is exponential
in there
so the question is uh can we can we do
better can we improve
this balance again one of the main
conjecture
so i should mention the word the name of
the
valiant is that
the determinant complexity of the
prominent
cannot be bounded by any polynomial in m
it also more to ban the determinative
complexity by these
exponential expressions is can we do
better can we do much better can we get
some polynomial or is it impossible
and why is that impossible can we get
lower bounds
what about
that's
one of the main challenges to get
interesting level down so the downbounds
we know are really weak
so any questions so far
so i should mention because it's not
completely obvious that the
determinant of the determinant
complexity of the prominent
is strictly bigger than m
at least for n
b and 2.
so i gave this as an exercise in the
homework it's not completely obvious
but for example the uh
geometry can help if you want to think
of this question geometrically you
can write the results
in a rather straightforward way
so maybe it's time to use some
geometry tools
so the geometric approach would be to
try to so suppose we have um
suppose there is equality here that you
can do what we did
what we did for n equal to also just
change a little bit of matrix
to the determinant and by some miracle
get the problem
okay so the degrees are the same so in
general you can t
to be a fine so the degrees are the same
you can just take it linear
to get the fun part it would mean that
the uh
so we can look at the determinant as an
opponent has given
as describing some hyper surfaces okay
so there is a geometric locus
so inside the space of matrix
we have a hyper surface given by the
condition the determinant equals zero
upper surface of singular matrices
this is a geometric object you can try
to understand this
hypersurface geometrically and wonder is
it totally different from the permanent
okay because if we have this identity so
you can also
look at the same operation at the end
permanent on hypersurface in the space
of matrix of matrices
and they are
linearly equivalent
which implies that geometrically they
really look the same they're just like
the one
so let's should have the same geometric
crop
and that's not the case for
for many reasons
so what what what would be that relevant
geometrically to distinguish
two hybrid surfaces for example we can
so of course we know the determinant of
surface much better than we do
for the permanent again because there is
this
property i mentioned in the beginning
that it is a
character of the general linear group so
there's an action of the general linear
group that preserves it
and so the structure is very simple from
the point of view
this does not happen from for the
permanent which is much more complicated
so for example we can look at the
singular locus
so it's better to look at these upper
surfaces inside the
projectilization
these are two homogeneous polynomials so
these upper surfaces are just caused
i forget about the cone structure but
i'm going to be
factoring out the scatter
collective action then the similar
so we need to do that single request is
a set of mattresses
of rank well these are
rank small strictly smaller than m
similar locus
set of matrices whose rank is almost n
minus two
and so on you can look at the set of
mattresses and it's singular locus
something which is geometrically natural
take the singular focus
matrices of ranks
lesson minus three et cetera
by going to singular
single low side again and again i'll
eventually get the matrices of rank one
and these are precisely the
different singular strata they are the
orbits
of the action of the
the linear group cannot bymatch this
from the left
from the right let's preserve the rank
and the orbits
okay so so we can just prove the
possibility of the existence of this
transformation t by saying that if these
hypersurfaces are linearly equivalent
then they will have the
same singular locus and the singular
loci will have the same singular locus
so in the end on the side of the
determinant we get the
measures of rank one
you go directly to uh two matrices of
rank one
this is smooth there is no single locus
two by two mattresses
and they are singular and they are just
hang on
no singular
is there any chance that you could find
a point that's on one hypersurface but
not the other
a family of points
yeah if they're different than they lose
they should be important
but i mean you need you need to know
there's not a linear map that maps one
to the other so if you exhibit one point
okay so with one point which has really
different geometric properties
um
but that's really i mean that's really a
very very weak okay so
we would like to do much better than
that we have to exclude the
possibility to to have some polynomial
down
okay so we must prove that eventually
this is bigger than any polynomial
to be much more feminine
so another geometric property
which is very specific to the
determinant of hypersurface
is that it contains a big linear spaces
so it's interesting to look at linear
spaces
because it really is something very
specific to the
determinant hypersurface
contains many big linear spaces
and by the way it's a very it's an old
and very interesting question to
understand the linear spaces in
in the space of mattresses
it's very far from being it seems to be
very basic and
a difficult question that there are many
interesting phenomena
very soon very
unexpected facts
so that's something we don't really
understand and that would be very
nice to understand
so many big inner spaces so you can just
look at the
the tech folk for example when column
equal to zero
so it does not really distinguish the
determinant from department because this
is also containing the
permanent hole and for surface
but the part here is that you have the
section of the of the group so you can
just move the
the linear space by the group so which
means that
what does it mean here just you have a
corner you look at all the
linear maps which have a given colon
space which i can call here okay
ce1 to say that the this line is in
the color of the mattresses
of this linear space okay and here we
have a big family of
such spaces for each line you can
consider the space of matrices
which vanish on this defined linear
transformation that vanish on this line
so this gave again a big linear space
and most of them will not be contained
in the equivalent
so the big difference here is that we
can cover
so by using these spaces we can include
any
uh singular matrix of course
okay so we have a family of big inner
spaces that will cover the
upper surface but for the permanent we
have a
also big inner spaces but they do not
cover
so in fact to get an inner space of this
size you will get to
fix one line of one column of zeros you
have a finite number of this
will not cover the upper surface
okay so the point is that
what i would like to say is that the
determinant on hypersurface is
very flat
everywhere
geometrically this is how i would like i
would understand this
at the front you have a big linear space
so the upper surface is flat in some
sense
so we can make it more precise
so
okay so more precisely thank you
so let's choose any any singular matrix
so maybe not any but one whose rank is
exactly n minus one
suppose
a is a matrix
i'll bring n minus one
so what is nice here once again is that
we have this uh gln action
established that there's normal form so
up to
up to the action of gn times jln you can
suppose that
a is just
the simplest matrix from n minus one
just from
the diagonals and zeros
and then we want to understand the
determinant of hypersurface near this
point
so it means that we just add
something small
okay and see what happens
one plus x one one two
one plus n x minus one x x minus one x
okay so then what is the uh expansion of
these determinants
so can we get uh degree one
factors we have to choose the ones on
the diagonal
multiplied by x and m
that's the only degree of factor we
could get expansion
but about degree two factors so we have
to choose
all these diagonal entries
minus one and just keep the one
okay so for example
so we take the ones here except for this
one
which we have to multiply by this
okay we have this two by two minors this
two by two minor
which we contribute to the db2 term
okay so the sum of x
i i x and m minus
x and i thanks iden
from i from one to n minus one
okay that's the only degree two
contributions
so what what is this what does it tell
us
so of course the linear term is just the
equation of the tangent hyperplane
of the upper surface
i just understand what about the degree
two term so you see that
maybe i can rewrite it
slightly differently so i have this x
and n appearing everywhere so
it's x and n
and the sum of the other diagonal
entries
and then
products x and i x i n
so once again this is the
engine hyperplane
so now the degree two part of the
interior expansion
we see that there is something very
special happening
so it's a quadratic form
a priori in the m2 n square
entries of the matrix
but the rank turns out to be very small
see the products of linear form as a
quadratic form this has rank 2.
have some factor of rank two each of
these factors
has rank two again we have n minus one
of these
so the rank is in fact
banded like equal to 2n
so let's call this qa
let's go ahead form so this is the way
we see that the
upper surface is flat you have
the rank which is much much smaller
than the dimension
now we can use this to compare with the
permanent
because suppose that
we can solve our problem so we can
express the
prominence as a determinant
so suppose that permanent
m by m matrices can be written as a
determinant of
n by n
matrix of a fine
expression in the entries of x
okay so what does it mean we have a this
means that t defines a
map from the space of m times n matrices
two m times n matrix mattresses
castles so we have the um
determinant hyper surface and we really
cut out cut it out by the um
as the geometry picture
cut it out by the image of t and the
intersection should be the
problem
so the determinant is flat it's very
flat
by cutting by some inner space
you still get some flatness
okay so to be more precise you have
something like this
suppose we have a
the matrix b here
go to some matrix a so you just compute
the um
entire expansion of the prominence
before m was bigger
now if i want to compute the
so the permanent
of something which would be
let's say y plus b okay so
complete this as a determinant of
the image by t so it should be a plus
which is the linear part
okay was a fine so if i apply t to b
plus something i get
a plus something which depends linearly
on one
okay so so i get something which will be
linear
y plus
so my linear form my quadratic from qa
applied to intel down y
and you can look at the intel expansion
on the other side
it makes something linear plus
it should be the same plus the quadratic
part of detail expansion will be
permanent
be careful again
and here again
okay so but so now i have this linear
transformation but
it does not matter if i consider the
rank this does not affect the rank
the conclusion is that the rank
this quadratic form which depends only
on the
the prominent
that most bounded by is bounded by 2nd
so
so now that's this point that we will
really prove that the
permanent is going different from the
determinant so remember that i i
mentioned the fact that
these uh the permanent hypersurface
contains
these large inner spaces that make the
variety very flat but this linear
species did not cover the variety
okay so in fact at the generate point
the uh the upper surface is not so flat
and uh in fact if you
if you choose that's a computation that
is not so difficult but if you choose
b is a generic matrix
and you have your surface
and this quadratic form is
non-degenerate
so
so that's really uh
said it's a computational exercise
you can do this explicitly so this
generic statement means that you just
have to choose one good matrix and do
the computation
if you can do that you're done
so there is a
simple matrix here is a simple metric
that works
this is really zero so it's on the upper
surface
so what do what do you what did you did
you see the the quality form is
non-degenerate it means the tracks is
the dimension
the dimension is m square so what are
the interests of that matrix
sorry they are all ones
the entries are one except this one
which is one minus n
so that improvement comes
it makes the computation easy because
it's when you do the uh
expansion value or columns
it does not depend so much on the
conditions
you can do it
so the conclusion is really that in the
end this crank is
m square
we get get a lower bound that's what we
were looking for
that's terrain which is due to a minion
and we said
really 10 years ago
that the determinant of complexity of
the permanent
is at least n square divided by two
okay so in particular if you take n
equal three for example
it is five five six or seven this is
still to be decided
so still so this is a very nice result
because
we've seen that we already had to
struggle to prove that the determinant
was
it is bigger than m and not equal to it
and here we get
something which is much stronger so this
is very nice because um
this is a quadratic so it's really it
was really a breakthrough
the produced bad lower bounds were just
linear
and really what what is nice also that
this geometric approach
is really elementary and proof is really
easy
it looks like this computation which is
a bit comfortable but
not so much but still
this is temple in engine of course so
if you want to
approach the volume conjecture we need
to get bands which are not polynomial
so last week i will explain different
approach we formulate the problem and
see how
geometry can be helped to go beyond this
thank you very much
so we built in lots of time for
questions so feel free to ask
any kind of question especially
elementary questions or most welcome
because we have 15 minutes for questions
and we still have a full
coffee break after that so don't be shy
what's known about the dual variety of
the camera
so this kind of imply that the dual is
not regenerated
so that's something i wanted to mention
which is the existence of these big
linear spaces and
due to the fact that it can be
interpreted as
a consequence of the fact that the the
dual is very degenerate
be the the variety that characterizes
the
planes
explain briefly what is it
okay so suppose you have just
you can do that in general but suppose
we have a hypersurface
in some projected space
if you look at the
the smooth points
then you have the tangent type of plate
to the upper surface which is a
hyperplane and
projected space
so then as you know there is this uh
uranium projective spaces which is the
the dual protective space characterizes
hyperplane so we can see these
hyperplanes as points
dual protective space okay so the family
i decided to play this code with jeweled
ready
usually it's denoted let's do x-star
inside the dual projective space like
this
and you have to be careful because
you can have singular points so you have
to take some closure
some point but that doesn't matter so
much so
you have this interesting geometric
object that you can associate to
the hypersurface and you expect that in
general
all the hyper hyperplane will be more or
less different
okay so i expect that in general
this dual is again a hyper surface
and while when this is not the case this
means that the
upper surface you started with has some
interesting challenging problems
and uh it's really the case that uh
if you start from the determination
hyper surface yeah
you don't get
hypersurface when you go to the dual
variety in fact you're
very far from getting an upper surface
localization of the space of mattresses
the dual so it is the variety of rank 1
mattresses
you can see that as a product of two
copies of project space inside
so the dimension of x
is n squared minus 2
and the dimension of x dual which
we would have expected to be the same is
in fact 2 n minus two
we sure have exactly the same numbers
that we got for the
ranks
the rank of general generically of this
um degree two part of the terror
expansion
this is the rank that we got the
determinants which is not coincidence
so we can so so
that's indeed something which strongly
distinguishes the determinant from the
permanent because
the determinant has this very small dual
variety
if you start from the permanent the dual
is
so maybe i can mention that this is
something we use to
improve a little bit the result of the
the consequence of this this approach is
that
the permanent not only is
determinator complexity at least n
squared divided by 2
but cannot be approximated by
polynomials with
this determinant complexity
it cannot be decimated
a slightly stronger statement
of the terminal complexity
smaller or equal and squared
but yes it's true that we probably know
anything about this dual upper surface
and it's surprising that
we finally know so little about um
the geometry of these two upper surfaces
even for the determinant determinant of
case
it's um it's really astonishing if you
think about the linear spaces
there's some strong phenomenon
really strange that you really don't
understand it's such a natural question
to understand
which inner spaces are contained in the
in the determinant what are the maximal
inner spaces of a
singular mattresses let's try to get
some more questions
okay so is it possible to improve this
instead of looking in permanent loop on
our polynomials
that's
i mean other polynomials which would be
relevant for this complexity game
but in fact like an issue with a kind of
statement with
a is not included in determinant and
square is kind of
exactly the boundary which it used
nothing for for complexity
so you need to improve it like this but
if you maybe if you can improve it for
any other polynomial
okay so you mean permanent is really
representative of
this sharpie um class and we could
possibly find some other sequence of
polynomials that would be easier to
enter
it's easier to move forward but it
wasn't
determined
i should ask for any sequence of
polynomials the questions that you see
obviously yes if you ask for
entrepreneurs that are relevant to
complexity
electrical
okay so this theorem this very nice term
like minimum it's 10 years old
can can you say anything about higher
order invariants do you get any more
um by looking at the next term in the
taylor expansion
you can't say many things about the
underworld
you don't get a better value
is it because we just don't understand
it or it will not give a better value
is there anything interesting about the
topology of these varieties
topology well you know there is a
huge amount of works in the topology of
these
discriminants because there is a whole
literature
for the determinant for the problem
maybe you know that
one more question so if does the
prominent behave
generically in the sense if i write down
the n factorial terms and i put random
coefficients rather than just plus plus
plus plus one
is from this point of view of these do
you expect the permanent to be
like the generic point over with the
support
the smaller is what is expected from the
fact that it represents a misconception
you say yes
depends what you mean by generic i don't
know from the for example the degree of
the dual hypersurface
do you expect that this attains to the
ginger if i take a generic
you know some degree of the dual do you
think it's attained
in that case yes you think so
it's more than a feeling it's a belief
it's a a
belief based on certain calculations in
small cases
so still the permanent that's singular
is
yes so it could affect the degree of the
dual in some ways
if you take a generic polynomial with n
factorial
coefficient its complexity will be
2 to the n log n whereas the permanent
has complexity
and upper bound we know two to the n so
in that sense permanent is not
so generic okay
can you say why we restrict just to
align changes of coordinates like
maybe if we allow quadratic changes of
coordinates
then you get some other bound but then
you can get a better bound
paying for it by quadratic change is not
so bad
i don't really know
if you allow you know for degree for
size and determinants maybe you allow
half the
degree of where you're changing the
coordinates or
you're sort of trading off a little bit
maybe it makes sense it seems to make
just the place
you can show that they you can simulate
that with lit with applying things also
so if you had something with you can
just make the tournament slightly bigger
instead of letting quadratic entries you
have that fine energy i mean i don't
know the example of where this
polynomial is
so you can just reduce the distance
okay well maybe now we're cutting into
coffee break so
that's that's the speaker again
no